foreign
for another round of facts or your
friends let's do it
all right today we are talking about
the mental health benefits of exercise
and this will probably be the shortest
facts of your friends that we've ever
done
the mental health benefits of exercise
so I just went to um pull up the
one of the the top academic journals on
the planet nature
here's just a couple of Snippets
we conclude that exercise may be a way
to reduce depression and pain and
improve the quality of life in adult
subjects with fibromyalgia and should be
a part of the treatment for this
pathology that's kudo
that who's the lead author on that paper
another paper a small a paper by the way
is another is just an inside way of
saying uh Journal article academic
Journal article a research study that
was done and that was written and
published at top tier Journal which call
it a paper
small study it was not a big study but
it was an important study
the paper is by Patton who was the lead
author
highlights the potential of hit which is
intense exercises
for improving Mental Health
in overweight women
with polycystic ovar ovary syndrome
it may be a viable strategy to reduce
symptoms of depression and anxiety in
women with PCOS polycystic ovary
syndrome
another paper by mock MLK
he was the lead author and there's a
bunch of other authors on there combined
resistance and endurance inter
interventions elicited significant long
lasting improvements in global fatigue
and were beneficial to the remaining
side effects individually resistance and
endurance interventions not
significantly improve these side effects
resistance interventions elicited higher
benefits overall
exercise interventions have lasting
clinical benefits in ameliorating at
adjuvant therapy side effects which
negatively impact fitness and mental
wear well-being
and I believe this was in
women with breast cancer I may got that
wrong I think this was a this was
dealing with women who were dealing with
um cancer treatment
suggesting that weight training and
cardiovascular exercise cardio
doing those things together
helped the entire process
studies show
um this is from Lawrence Robertson
Robinson studies show that exercise can
treat mild to moderate depression as
effectively as antidepressant medication
but without the side effects
similar studies in the bajillions
discuss that about anxiety
I have personally
experienced a significant reduction in
OCD symptoms with
intense exercise
on the regular
I've also felt a reduction in ticks I
have several ticks where I blink or I'll
move my head or I'll count
a significant reduction in those as well
sleep is improved
exercise improves cellular function
it helps reset your nervous system
helps with chronic inflammation over the
long period of time after an extreme
bout of exercise or Hard Exercise
inflammation does rise in your body and
it actually has shown that that's kind
of it serves a purpose
but over time
it also helps with psychosomatic issues
when you feel chronic pain but doctors
are telling you we don't see any reason
why you should be hurting maybe there's
a psycho it's psychological in origin
lowers all cause mortality as the great
Dr Peter attia says
helps give us stronger bones muscles
you have to exercise if you want to be
well
ta-da
if you want to really nerd out about
this stuff
you can check out Dr huberman's podcast
especially he's got a multi
um series podcast with Dr Andy Galpin
who's just a savant you can check out Dr
Tia's work you can check out our friend
Elaine Norton's work Dr Lane Norton you
can check out the Mind pump guys
I cannot
emphasize this enough
mental health the way we have described
mental health and I say we I'm a member
of the mental health practitioner
Community we have described mental
health as simply the act of getting all
of your thoughts in the right order just
thinking the right thoughts and that's a
lie it is false
I had one professor and I haven't very
verified this with data just with a
professor a grad one of my doctoral
professors
told me that
Sigmund Freud the father of modern
psychotherapy
had really bad teeth issues and you know
he's got a well-documented cocaine issue
and he used cocaine to numb his gums
because he had bad teeth he was
self-conscious of his teeth and he was
so self-conscious that he had his
clients lay down and face the other way
so the whole Foundation of counter
transference and don't let your patient
look at you and just let them free
associate may have originated if my
professor was telling me the truth
from a man's being self-conscious about
the way his face looked
why do I tell you that
that is the basis of Mental Health
it's just talking and talking and
talking and talking and thinking and
fixing your thinking and talking and
talking and we've completely divorced
the body from the mind
so I'll say this as clear as possible
your brain can't function the way it was
designed to function if it is sitting
atop a body that is falling apart
the stress chemicals that cycle through
your body were designed for fight or
flight responses not click and type and
more murder podcast
that was a low blood Kelly
that wasn't very nice sorry
here's the deal
go for a walk
every day
Dr Emily nagotsky talks about folks who
just would look at her and say I I'm not
going to exercise I'm not going to move
I don't feel comfortable I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know any of these
exercises everyone's like you should
deadlift and squat I don't even know
what that is Squad is something I do in
the woods when I go to the bathroom and
there's no right I don't know what this
stuff is
So she recommends laying your bed
and start with your feet
and squeeze your feet as hard as you can
Flex them
and then relax and then move up your
body from your calves
to your hamstrings to your glutes to
your
quads all the way up neck your face and
then do that several times is that going
to be enough over the long term no not
at all it's a place to start
you can't be well unless you have a
practice of movement and exercise in
your daily life
um I haven't read the original paper so
I haven't talked about it here but
um
I did see a headline recently that of
all we've been talking about
microplastics and all this stuff and
pollute all this drama about the
lowering testosterone rates globally
and there's some indication it may
simply be we have moved from a
movement-based society to a sedentary
based society our bodies have said oh we
don't need this anymore
and it's going to stop making it because
that's how good our bodies are we don't
don't use it we lose it
all of the data I've seen over the last
couple of years suggests that weight
training is the single most important
thing you can do
followed by what they call zone two
which is
long steady state exercise where you can
still carry on a conversation so we're
walking
maybe a little bit of a Brisk Pace but
we're just walking we can still have a
conversation talk Chit Chat all the time
you can run an exercise bike and just
watch a show
write an exercise bike and read a book I
do that when I'm doing zone two or
listen to a podcast
and then once or twice a week every two
weeks just have a blowout session just
go really hard for a few minutes
and if you want to go down rabbit holes
on this please go go see my my buddies
at mind pump please go follow Dr Lane
Norton or Dr Tia
There's real you can you can go to the
ends of the Earth with this stuff
but if all of us would make movement a
daily part of our lives but we would see
in short order as a less anxious Society
a less depressed Society
a society that could think a little bit
clearer that could show up for each
other a little bit better
I have a habit of overdoing it and I
remember uh this is back in 2013
I was pushing it so hard that I just
swore I'm not gonna lift for 60 days and
I just started walking around my
neighborhood in the morning for an hour
I lost 30 pounds
obviously I altered my diet what not two
but just simply the stress
so sometimes crushing and killing us no
it's not the right season
sometimes let's sign up for a marathon
let's just go do that
obviously obviously obviously meet with
your doctor
but please
for your kids
for your spouse
for your country
for your spiritual life for you
make movement make exercise a regular
part of your life
lift weights three to five days a week
go for a walk
if you don't know how to lift weights
that's right
there's enough resources on the Internet
or go see a trainer for a couple times
and they'll walk you through some basic
things
Now's the Time
make movement a part of your everyday
life
and that's the platform
from where we can build
a mentally healthy life